one scene in Oppenheimer had the
physicist grandson wishing for some
additional editing and it may not be the
one you think minor spoilers for
Oppenheimer ahead director Christopher
Nolan put significant effort into the
accuracy of his biopic about J Robert
Oppenheimer the man who spearheaded the
effort to build the first atomic bomb he
told the Washington Post that he
literally hopped the fence of the
scientist Los alamo's home while
scouting locations early in the
production process I don't think his
story offers any easy answers at all
since this release viewers have been
busy dissecting the film's various
details at Great length analyzing the
accuracy of everything from stars on
flags to era specific cigarette packs
oppenheimer's descendants are also
speaking up about the film his grandson
Charles Oppenheimer shared his Source on
the film with time he didn't see the
movie until it was released and found it
mostly to be a faithful portrayal of his
grandfather's life Charles said as a
dramatized representation of the history
it was really largely accurate there are
parts that I disagree with but not
really because of Nolan Charles flagged
one moment he really didn't care for and
contended that that wasn't grounded in
historical fact it's the one when
Oppenheimer nearly poisons his Professor
Patrick blackett Charles said he blames
a troublesome seen on the 2005 biography
that inspired the film saying the part I
like the laces as poison apple reference
which was a problem in American
Prometheus there's no record of him
trying to kill somebody that's a really
serious accusation and this historical
revision there's not a single enemy or
friend of Robert Oppenheimer who heard
that during his life and considered it
to be true it's worth noting that
Charles Oppenheimer didn't have a
relationship with his grandfather
Charles was born there Santa Fe New
Mexico but not until after both of his
paternal grandparents had passed away
Charles told time that despite his late
arrival the family had a very open
dialogue about his grandfather's
connection to his father Peter
Oppenheimer who even spent several years
of his childhood living at Los Alamos
while the Manhattan Project was underway
Charles explained to time that the
family's basic policy toward what they
call the cult of Oppenheimer is to stay
hands off he said it's a business to
write and talk about Oppenheimer and the
model that my dad choses it's not very
classy and I'm not going to be involved
in publicly representing Oppenheimer in
ways that other people do as a business
Charles did briefly talk to Nolan during
the production and although he didn't
love the apple scene he ultimately was
content to let Nolan tell the story the
way he wanted Charles said I definitely
would have removed the Apple thing but I
can't imagine myself giving advice about
movie stuff to Nolan he's an expert he's
the artist and he's a genius in this
area but one amusing family story is
that if I invited myself to the set they
would entertain me coming which I did
twice it was during one of these visits
that one other noteworthy historical
inaccuracy bubbled up to the surface
Charles Oppenheimer visited the
Oppenheimer set twice during filming one
of these visits was in New Mexico where
Charles witnessed a filming of a scene
where Killian Murphy who plays Robert
Oppenheimer enters a room and delivers a
line that includes a curse word Charles
told time when I went back to Santa Fe
and told my dad he was horrified he said
Robert Oppenheimer never swore he was
such a formal person he would never ever
do that what can I tell them despite
private worries that abenheimer would
feature an over-the-top portrayal of his
title character Charles shot the event
up to the creative Liberty that comes
with any adaptation all the same the
family was nervous that the film might
have a slightly more colorful take on
their patriarch than they would have
liked then the movie came out and their
anxieties were relieved Charles said I
think he said one swear word in the
movie and I just happened to be in the
room so there is a chance that if we
have been consultant we could have added
some details and depth but there's such
a complete record it was enough for
Nolan to tell the story he intended to
based on the feedback from most people
coming out of theaters so far it seems
most would agree with the grandson's
conclusion
[Music]